it is ok everyone how's everybody doing
really cool to be at Cascadia j/s the
first year so I've known Carter for a
long time and the first Cascadia JSI
helped out for a hot minute but i never
actually made it to the event so i'm
really stoked to be here today talking
about a topic I'm really passionate
about which is mentoring just to tell
you a little bit about me I've been in
the industry yeah I'm old I've been in
the industry a little over 20 years I
started off my career as a software
developer and then halfway in I moved
over to the product side and I worked at
some great companies doing product
Microsoft Splunk
cloud did a lot of open source really
passionate about working with community
and lately I've also been getting really
involved with stem helping people of
diversity I'm also an advisor for code
fellows and that fits really well with
the topic that I'm going to speak about
today which is mentoring how many people
here actually have a mentor just a few
of you anybody here who is a mentor okay
well if I come back a year from now I'm
gonna try to make sure a lot more hands
go up
I particularly want for people that are
I know we have a lot of folks that are
the scholars that are looking to get
into the tech industry please pay
attention to this talk because I think
mentoring is something that really can
help you and it has really helped me in
my own career and for those of you that
have been around awhile really I'm going
to encourage you also to mentor others
and you can give back and you can help
them and a lot of folks today are
concerned about a lot of the barriers
that we know that people face in the
industry and mentoring is one way to
help overcome those barriers I'll talk a
bit a bit more about that as we go
forward let's start off we're talking
about what is a mentor so the first
thing that a mentor is is a guide and an
advisor now you'll see here I have a lot
of mountainous pictures so I've gotten
really into like mountaineering and rock
climbing recently so but
one of the things about mountaineering
and rock climbing is you're trying to
get to some type of peak you're trying
to get to some destination and you need
help to do that and that's really one
one of the things that a mentor does
they're a guide they've been to places
that you haven't been and they can
advise you along the way
generally a mentor is somebody who's
gone out of their way to volunteer
because they want to enable others to be
successful now this could be somebody
who works in your company and they're
paid but still when you look at
different organizations where people
mentor that's generally something that
they're doing because they want to do
that and that's something you should
think about as a mentee that the person
that's doing this is doing this because
they want to not because they have to
generally a mentor is going to have more
experience than you do
they're going to be able to help you in
an area where you want to grow so let's
talk about some of the ways that a
mentor can help you many successful
people and there's an article recently
in Forbes magazine about this will tell
you that mentors have been key to their
success why well one of the things that
a mentor can do is provide insight they
can see things that you can't see they
can look at things at a different level
that maybe you're not looking at and
they can help you to kind of navigate
difficult types of situations with that
insight that they provide in particular
I found in my own career when I had
mentors that were very very senior to me
who had been around a long time in the
industry they would be able to have that
kind of insight a lot of us are
developers so another place this can
help is like if you're working on a
problem and you have a mentor they may
be able to say oh you probably actually
really want to solve it this way because
this is going to have these implications
I know this because of these other types
of systems that we've built in the past
a key thing that mentors can provide is
a safe space so often and a mentor does
not have to be in your company
most of many of my mentors
do not work in the same company that I'm
in and one of the advantages of that is
they can be much more objective I can
talk to them about my situation I don't
have to be able I don't have to hold my
tongue and I can say you know I really
have this problem that I'm going through
I don't know what to do
this person is pissing me off I can't
figure this thing out and they can sit
there objectively and and give you some
advice on how to be able to deal with
that situation they can also really help
you to fill gaps in your skills so they
can say you know you can go to a mentor
and say hey I really want to learn this
thing can you help me and many times you
will find that the answer you will get
will be yes and there's many different
ways that a mentor can help one if it's
at your job you can possibly shadow them
so they can basically say hey come along
and as I go through this thing I'll
bring you with me
so you can shadow and you can learn
other mentors maybe they'll just sit
down with you and they'll walk you
through something I'll give you an
example and let me just point this out
mentoring is something you can find a
mentor at any point in your career it's
not something that you have to be junior
I have many mentors and I've been in the
industry for a long time and in my
current job where I work I I stepped
into a role where I had much more scope
and I had to do things that I never had
to do before like dealing with pricing I
never dealt with pricing before I've
written lots of code I never dealt with
pricing so I reached out to our VP of
Finance in the company and said hey can
you help and he was able to do that he
was able to walk me through point me out
literature that would help me to get the
foundation that I needed to be able to
make the types of decisions I was going
to have to make another key thing that
mentors can do and which was extremely
helpful for me in my career is they can
connect you to their network they can
make lots of different connections to
people that will help you in your
advancement to give you an example early
on when I joined Microsoft I joined in
one role as a product planner actually
to blog post about this and I realized
that that wasn't really the place that I
wanted to be but I was working with a
lot of different partners in different
product teams at Microsoft and I was
trying to make those connections by just
doing good work and being being reliable
and that led to me basically shifting my
entire career through those connections
because one of the people that I worked
with was on the product side and he said
hey you should consider doing this he
connected me with other program managers
and that had an amazing effect on my
career so I would really advise making
those kinds of connections is really
going to benefit you and there's a lot
of different ways that you can do that
from meetups
to social - in your own work environment
another thing that mentors can do is
they can create opportunities because
you're in the back of the mentors mind
and they're thinking about you whoever
the mentor is when an opportunity comes
up that they think might be a good fit
for you they can actually put your name
in and I've seen this happen several
times in my own career like when I was
at Microsoft I had a mentor who was a
partner at Microsoft he'd been there for
a very long time so I didn't work for
him and he became my mentor because I
approached him and asked him I just said
hey can you be my mentor and he said
sure I'll do that because somebody had
advised me that having mentors was a
good thing and he actually created tons
of opportunity in my career where he
said oh yeah he heard about something
that was happening at a different
organization and said that's a good fit
for Glen let's let's get Glen to do that
so let's talk about the different types
of career mentors there actually are
many different mentors you can have life
mentors but I'm gonna I classify career
mentors into kind of three so there's a
role focused mentor that's somebody who
really just helps you do your job they
know your job better than you and they
can help you do that and many
organizations have like a buddy system
for example where you join in a
particular role and your junior they're
going to assign somebody to you but a
key thing I would say about mentoring is
you can go after it you don't have to
wait til somebody comes to you and says
oh we have a mentoring program and we
want to match you up you can go out
there and you can find a mentor to fill
the gaps that you've identified career
growth focused so a career growth
focused mentor is kind of like the one
that I mentioned before somebody who
generally has a lot more experience they
may be much more senior than you and
they're looking across a much broader
perspective and they're helping you to
see things from a different angle so for
example the person that I mentioned his
name was John Gossman I remember when I
was at Microsoft when there were some
things that were going on within the
organization that I didn't understand
and I was able to go to him and say hey
can you explain this to me and he would
look at he would show it to me from a
completely different perspective and
over time I actually started to see
things from that perspective so that's
how mentoring really helped me it helped
me to basically orientate my lens to
look at things in a different way and to
start to think of things in a broader
perspective you can also get a mentor
that helps you just with a very specific
skill I talked I gave you my pricing
example where I just wanted to learn how
to do pricing and I went to somebody who
really knew pricing to work with me see
I think I'm missing a slide no actually
no those are all of them ok so let's
talk about what makes a good mentor one
key thing is that a mentor is more
experienced than you now many people may
be thinking well how much experience do
I have to have really to be a mentor
really you just have to have experience
that somebody else needs and why I'm
saying that is you don't have to wait
until you have 10 years of experience in
industry for example to be a mentor as
long as you have acquired a certain
amount of knowledge that you think that
other people need you can actually be a
mentor to that to that individual a
mentor should be somebody that you feel
comfortable talking to
they're gonna help you and they're only
going to be able to help you in as much
as you're able to give them the
information that they need to help you
be successful what are your goals what
are your desires what are the things
that you're actually struggling with I'm
not saying they're a therapist let's
keep it in the work kind of career
context but you should feel comfortable
talking to them I often advise people
that are trying to find mentors to
really look at this if you don't feel
comfortable talking to that person
you're not really going to be they're
not really going to be able to help you
and you're not really gonna be able to
find the help that you need
trust this goes hand-in-hand with that
as well the whole idea of a mentor is
someone that you feel that you can
reveal to them a whole bunch of details
in order for them to be able to help you
but you're not gonna do that if you feel
you can't trust them so one thing about
trust really is confidentiality that's
what that means that the things that are
told to the mentor stay with the mentor
or at least that mentor gets your
permission and will say that so I mentor
a lot of people and I will say are you
okay if I say so and so I'm not gonna
just go go ahead and do it on my own
this has certainly been a challenge for
me they have to be a good listener the
mentor is really there to serve you
remember that if you get a mentor it's
not that you're there to make the mends
who are happy the whole idea of the
mentor is to help you make that journey
if they're not a good listener they're
not gonna really be understanding and
understanding your problems and they're
not gonna be giving you the space to
really try to work through them because
a mentors job is not to solve the
problem for you that's the whole idea of
advice it's to help you see help you
look at things in a different way think
about how to get up that trail but
you're the one who ultimately has to do
it consistency and availability is
really important now there's a
relationship that builds between a
mentor and a mentee and there's an
agreement that happens and whatever that
agreement is as far as availability and
time that should be something that the
men
or sticks to it's also on the menti it
goes both ways but if you have a mentor
that's flaking out who's not willing to
give the time then you should find
another mentor who is willing to give
that time because otherwise you're just
you're just wasting your time and you're
not actually making the progress so I
wanted to give a couple of pointers
about how to find a mentor so one thing
you can do is many companies do have a
mentoring program and one thing I always
found kooky just telling a story is that
Microsoft has a mentoring program and
they basically require at the time would
require required that you were an
employee for a year before you could get
a mentor I hope that's actually changed
because what I really needed the mentor
was earliest on so what did I do when
the program wouldn't really allow me to
be in it I just went and found a mentor
on my own anyway so you don't need the
program but if there is a program it can
be a really useful resource to be able
to connect with others you can just
approach a friend or a co-worker tell
your friend your coworker like hey
here's something I really like to learn
I think you have a bunch of experience
that I could benefit from would you be
willing to be my mentor and I have found
consistently that most of the time when
or I would say consistently when I've
gone to people and said to them hey
would you mentor me the answer is
generally a yes once in a while it might
be a no and if they're not at a place
where there will able to give that
commitment then no is actually a good
thing it's saving both of us a lot of
heartache and hardship a key thing I
would say too is that people respond to
honesty and when someone is genuine so
when you go to someone and ask them for
a mentor to be your mentor be prepared
to actually work because every mentor is
going to they're going to get
discouraged as a mentor if they see that
they're advising you or giving you like
they might say a mentor might say hey go
read this book this book is really going
to help you
well if you're not going to do those
things that the mentor is advising on
that's going to help you to learn then
that relationship is probably not going
to work out very well there's lots of
online communities where you can go to
find mentors one that because I come
from the product side one I'll call out
is the mind the product slack so for any
folks here that are interested in like
product management or learning more
about product they have a great
mentoring community there and you can
also use social media so this is my VP
of Marketing at all 0 we call them gonto
and he recently went went on Twitter and
he posted and said hey you know I'd like
to talk to somebody who has experience
in a company our size leading a product
team and that's because he was stepping
into an acting VP of Product role so
this is a good illustration of someone
who is quite seasoned in their career
who's going out there and asking for
help so you're never too old or too
experienced to ask for a mentor so I'm
gonna talk about a couple of other
things quickly which is why should you
mentor so there's we talked a lot about
the benefits of having a mentor but what
are the benefits of being a mentor one
key thing is just about do it's doing
good you're helping other people be
successful and if you believe in the
concept of pay it forward that when you
do good things it's going to come back
to you I truly believe in that and have
seen that so you are in a place to
really help other people be successful
in the industry and you can help break
barriers and this one has been really
personal for me you know I know for
example as a white male that I have had
a lot of advantages and I tweeted about
this a while ago I said I've gotten
double advantages one being white
another being male in technology and so
that puts me in a place where I feel
like I have a responsibility to help
break Briery
blah break barriers for others and I can
do that why because I can help them
introduce them to my network I can
advocate
I can guide them on what are the things
that they need to do in order to be
successful I can help the industry as a
mentor why because I'm helping to groom
the next generation I'm helping to make
sure that the people that are in this
industry care and are doing the right
things and I can inculcate in them the
right principles and things to care
about mentoring will help you be a
leader if you have aspirations of one
day for example being a manager then
mentoring is really going to help you
because you're gonna get a lot of the
experience a key thing of being a
manager is being able to listen and
being able to advise and you're going to
get a lot of that plus you're going to
understand the challenges that the
people that you're mentoring or going
through and all of that experience is
going to lead into helping you to be a
better leader and manager in the future
and this one is really really important
and and this is one of the reasons why
for myself I focused a lot over the last
number of years on mentoring women and
people of color is to just overcome your
unconscious biases and we all have them
it's not saying you're like a bad person
we all have these biases that we were
born you know that we've picked up
through our culture and we act based on
those biases but if you become conscious
of them you can it you can attack them
you can battle them and for me talking
to people that are in a very challenged
position and hearing their challenges
and understanding them and understanding
the things that I shouldn't do or should
do to help them has been super valuable
it's made me a better person
so getting close to the end but I have a
special treat coming up but I would
advise you all to go get a mentor and be
a mentor and you can have multiple
mentors so now for the last part of my
talk I've got somebody really special
that I want to bring up I've talked a
lot about how as a mentor you have this
opportunity to help other
and so I'm gonna bring up my friend
Taylor who has an amazing story of how
she went from not working in the tech
industry to getting a developer job in
just about a year it's a great story
come on up Taylor
can you guys hear me okay how are you
guys I'm really excited to be here it's
my first tech conference and so I wanted
to kind of quickly share with you my
story and how I landed a front end role
in Seattle so if he looks to the left
you'll see me January 29th of this year
working at Boston Market as a fast food
server slash cashier and then to the
right you see me on my first day as a
professional software engineer so going
back last year was when I started
learning how to code I couldn't afford
to go to a bootcamp or go back to
college for a computer science degree
and I didn't really have much of a
support system because I don't have a
college degree at all and I didn't know
anyone that was in stem and so how he
came across coding was because I watched
a documentary about Aaron Swartz Evie
you guys have heard of him he was the
co-founder of Reddit and he really tried
to use technology to impact politics and
that was what I was really passionate
about doing so I learned how to code
online through udemy.com
YouTube tutorials egghead and I built a
lot of projects and I'd sweeten my
progress every day on twitter using the
100 days of code challenge and i used
that as a way to not only document my
progress and see what I've been learning
like every day but also to connect with
people I started networking online I'm
an introvert and so I and I also cannot
like a force that goes like a meet-up or
anything because I was in Orlando
Florida and Orlando is dead when comes
to like tech opportunities so I was
unfortunate to be like in your Christie
aatul or anything like that but I was on
Twitter and I did get a hold of a lot of
people who provided like support from
like around the world encouragement
constructive feedback on my projects and
on my work and it really meant a lot to
me and so because of Twitter also I got
a hold
of an employer in Seattle they have
reached out to me and they had offered
me an interview and that is when I
landed my first role and I also wanted
to give like a little bit of advice to
people who are looking for like their
first job what really made me um stand
out to that employer and actually get
touched I was because I did go through
some technical interviews with other
companies and I remember like the
questions they asked me and so when I
interviewed with the lead front-end
engineer I asked him all those questions
that I was asked I was like I was like
hey so what design patterns do you like
or what is clean code mean to you I
asked like those kind of questions
um do you do unit testing performance
testing um you know I was just I flipped
back on him to actually show they're
like you know I know what I'm you know
like I know what I'm doing and that
really impressed them and so I got
offered the role and I just am now in
the process of wanting to like give back
to people so I'm also like mentoring
online on Twitter helping people out
provide like some kind of support system
and I hope that my story is impactful
and that I hope that it's helps people
who are struggling because I remember
those like late nights you know coding
like every night I would like work at
Boston Market for like eight to nine
hours a day like sweeping floors mopping
bathrooms and you know dealing with like
micro managers and like it was just like
all that pain and like everything I was
going through because at the time my dad
had died when I start learning how to
code it really really feels like my
energies to learn how to code and select
Larenz like my first like role in tech
and I know it's like when the most like
competitive industries and I know they
can get hard we didn't go into an
interview process but it does get better
and there will be a spot for you if you
just keep going and keep trying and just
putting yourself out there and building
projects so I hope this
thank you everyone